hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching
mind your decisions
here's a fun geometry problem
two semi-circles are drawn on adjacent
sides of a square with side length one
solve for the red area which is the area
outside of the semicircles
and where the semicircles overlap
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so i first solved this problem the long
way by solving for the area of the
overlap between the semi-circles
and then considering what the total area
would be
but there's a neat trick to solve this
problem
draw the diagonals of the square
now
rotate the circular segments about the
center of the square
we end up with the following diagram
now we can see
the red area is exactly half of the
square because it fills the area above
the diagonal
so the red area will be half of the
squares area so it will be one half
and we're done solving this problem
did you figure it out and which method
did you use
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watched
for free inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they
already have over a hundred million
views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos
watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description or you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support